[Music]
do you want to know what it is like to
be an international model
the real lifestyle the traveling well
I have just arrived at my new modeling
contract let me share my model lifestyle
with you
be an international male model you need
to be able to travel a lot you need to
go to a new country for two to three
months and stay there until your
contract is finished right now I'm on my
way to my new contract China
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo guys
good morning what's up so I've been here
in China for a couple of weeks and I'm
just gonna show you how a normal day
would look like for a model here in
China Saturday yeah we have to work on
weekends
[Music]
so I'm on my way to castings but before
then I'm just gonna stop at the agency
and show you how that looks like
[Music]
so this is my model agency here in
Guangzhou China models international I
came in here just to see the options or
the jobs that I have for this week
so here we have all the models and then
here's my card over here there you go so
the model card is like a very small CV
so when you go to the castings you give
this to the client and if they're
interested in you then they will call
back the agency and they will book you
for a job so China just like most
countries in Asia you cannot go to the
castings by yourself you need Booker's
to go with you that can translate
because you don't know their language
right so these are the a team in
Guangzhou based models in town
and we generally go to class things he
brings the food moving to the car
he's like God really healthy food you
know chicken some beings of white rice
and some tomato salad see the motto
lifestyle have to eat to stay healthy
this is Eric
look where he's taking us today the
castings and then Jesse or Jesse James
in the front
hey okay how how all right so that's the
team
this is our first casting for the day so
on the left is the models and on the
right side you have the clients how it
works is that plans will choose which
models they like and those models they
have to do some poses for the clients
this is the fourth agency and finally
this is us and I see there's a lot of
models in town so the competition is
quite tough so it's not that easy to get
a job all right so the client shows me
they wanted me to do some poses here so
that's what I'm doing I'm fitting the
clothes and I'm doing some poses with
the clothes and it's lined with the
looks to see if they're happy with it or
not
[Music]
this is our second casting for the day
[Music]
let's do this alright first up is
Nicolas so Michael is next
[Music]
this is Caron
[Music]
this is Joseph this is Martin and I'm
next guys
[Music]
so we are five models in this agency
however we are different ages and we do
have different styles which go home and
there we go home
here we go alright so that's a picture
the castings for today it's done
dude guys
hey guys I'm having a haircut
and they they massaging my in my head
it's anyway it's too good to talk to you
talk to you later
for us models who travel around the
world it's pretty hard to find a
hairstylist that you can trust so in
China this is the only guy I can trust
his name is Mike so one of the coolest
things about being a model is that you
travel and you see these different
cultures you live with these people and
see how they live every day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
so this is how I do my shopping here in
China
the festival
anyway yo yo yo yo
Oh
Oh
hey yeah
sequence
oh hey Jenny
thanks for watching the video if you
liked it please give me a like and a
thumbs up and subscribe to see some more
videos
[Music]